transparency apparently the order of the
day from the Belarusian Ministry of
Defense they promised they'd bring us
here to a base just south of Minsk and
here we are
the only life we find a few men asleep
but they're Belarusian nothing to do
with Wagner Mercenaries
the Belarusian leader Alexander
lukashenko had told us on Thursday that
he'd offered the Wagner group this base
and they'd said no
we do not build camps we offered them
several former military camps but PMC
Wagner have a different vision of their
encampment
what that vision is he couldn't tell us
but if they do end up here there are 300
tents at their disposal enough for 5 000
troops
so what are the immediate plans for
who's going to live here and when are
they going to move in
our main goal is to set up the
infrastructure so that if in a situation
where we have to defend our country
militarily we have the infrastructure
but they'd be welcome if they came that
is the message that we're getting
nothing to see here except for a large
training facility set up very fast for
slightly ambiguous goals
construction started right around the
time that pregojan set his men on Moscow
satellite images showing nothing here
before pragosan's Mutiny two days after
though already a sprinkling of tents
quiet is the nearby town of osipovic he
looks this is a military area belarus's
only ballistic missile Brigade The 465th
is based around here believed to have
recently taken delivery of Russian
nuclear-capable iskanda missiles
it would make sense then for Russian
tactical nuclear warheads to have been
delivered here too but that are
Belarusian hosts would neither confirm
nor deny
dynamagne Sky News osipovici Belarus